I've been having diarrhea all morning so
did my hair makeup to feel better about
myself
hi guys my name is grace felt like if
you do not know now you know your life
is different now
what kind of sucks a little bit hatred
seems to be spreading in a rapid pace
you skipped restricted mode policies
thing is kind of fitted up and did I
mention about having diarrhea all
morning but on top of all that is
International Day of happiness so I
thought what a perfect opportunity to do
another episode of good news is why
share with you some of the good and dumb
silly stories that I've found happening
in the world on the Internet
I'm going to check ourselves from
thinking about the crumbling cesspool of
humanity that we exist in on an everyday
constant basis and so maybe earth just
floats right into the Sun and then it's
all over
let's get started the really Western
crying kid of March Madness I saw these
clips over the weekend this kid is a
Northwest and fan at their March Madness
game and he is feeling about the sport
oh my god oh look it is me every day I
wake up and I realize I'm not dead yet
I'm kidding I would like this little boy
on a very spiritual level I recently
watched the movie big as an adult for
the first time and I also had a very
emotional reaction but this is great
news because this little boy established
an emotional response that you can
compare your current emotional state to
pretty sure no matter how sad angry
frustrated you are about whatever's
going on in your life you're not as
every set of frustrated as this little
boy oh if you wreck this emotionally to
a basketball game as that elicits woo
wait are you experienced but dating is
like as an adult next piece of good news
is I bought a vacation bad t-shirt for
my dog over the weekend and I made her
wear it and take photos with me
he looks like a retired middle-aged male
accountant and I love it I found little
busty this morning apparently visiting
this guy's sports so much he made it mad
I haven't watched it let's watch this no
oh my god the total of [ __ ] I put a
little yes it didn't at all oh my god oh
my god how does a boy go to the fancy
magician okay cowboy code in a top hat
chosen top hat
that's great news are we all just toads
and happened also of that man is not on
the next season of present runway I'm
going to be so pissed so here's the
story I found uh help you compose
quickly real fans have an epic party
after bedtime look at this party that
they are having these twins build a
pillow or on the ground which they just
roll in and then their parents come in
put them to bed put the pillows away and
then they get out of their cribs and
they do it again
they're literally Scrooge McDuck in the
opening of ducktales when he swims
through his room full of gold coins this
is also inspiring because these twins
really represent the idea of not letting
anyone keep you from having a great time
if it's not hurting anyone else although
this world is up for me okay kids
talking to so they're clearly
communicating with each other throughout
the night and that's kind of some type
of witchcraft to me but that aside these
are inspiring a little baby Oh another
piece of good news is that I'll
officially obsessed with work new song
greenlight and I've been putting it on
and repeat the last 48 hours in my car
in my house in my head and a lot of you
guys are telling me to comment on this
last weekend that Lord performed on SNL
girl has dance moves after my own heart
when I get to a certain level of drug
and I start dancing I think I look like
this but I know that I am Lord and
that's great news to not feel alone oh
here's some other good news these
headlines are dumb the only the Queen
eat eat mess where in the world the
a-listers are donning two pieces if you
think that your job
so someone created a heat mat to allow
the public to know where Ava celebrities
are wearing bikinis someone's job was to
do this check optimized but not for pot
brownie reaction rep said no follow-up
questions what all the questions we have
about the big chicken with the big
chicken who's the big chicken gaze upon
your new master this large chicken okay
let's watch this video holy pic that's a
big chicken why does it have feet like
paper that's the front half of a chicken
in the back half of an alpaca that's not
correct
I get that good news if you got really
bored of the night marriage that you've
been consistently having you have some
new material to shake them up a little
bit and giant chicken is where we wrap
up this episode of good nooses let me
know what kind of good news you guys
have bothered over the internet recently
and don't forget to subscribe to this
youtube channel because I put out videos
Monday Wednesday Friday sometimes and
click that little bell icon so you have
the notifications from a channel turned
on because my inconsistency is so
consistent you'll be yourself favor you
won't miss a video if you have the
notifications turns on I hope you guys
have a great Monday see you next video
I don't know I mean this big chicken
good suck it dick